blueeye Samurai is a show that looks
gorgeous with an insane cast and some of
the best action sequences I've seen in a
long time but the show also contains a
lot of twists and turns and unanswered
questions so in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into its ending and
explaining some of its biggest mysteries
but before we begin make sure to like
And subscribe the Shogun demands it most
of bluee Samurai takes place in 1657
Japan a period of isolation from the
outside world known as sakoku during
this time westerners were barred from
entering the country and children like
our protagonist Mizu were treated like
second class citizens because they were
half Japanese half Western this is why
we'll often see Mizu wear these glasses
to conceal her most telling Western
feature her blue eyes the series final
episode begins with a flashback to the
moment Mizu made her vow to track down
and kill her father she doesn't know who
her father is but she has narrowed it
down down to four men one of these men
raped her mother and was responsible for
making her this half breed monster a
source of all her life's Strife
additionally her father is said to have
engaged in the trade of young women for
prostitution as well as selling guns and
opium so she makes it her life's goal to
kill these four men at any cost I am
owed my revenge and I will have it at
any cost we'll see that Mizu has a
tattoo on her arm a cross with a DOT the
dot symbolizes one of the four men she's
already killed and it's assumed that
each quadrant will be filled with a DOT
once she has killed these men we never
see Mizu kill this first man and little
is known about him abija Fowler The
Season's main antagonist calls him
Violet with Violet already dead Mizu
moves on to Fowler a white man held in
an almost impenetrable Castle because
Japan does not allow westerners Fowler
is essentially held confined in this
building but given almost any luxury he
could desire because he secretly helping
the Shogun trade with the West making
the Shogun the second richest man in the
world Fowler will ask to dine alongside
the Shogun as reward for his good work
but is denied based on the color of his
skin this resentment has been building
in Fowler for over 10 years and thus he
has orchestrated a coup to take down the
Shogun install a puppet leader and Rule
Japan for himself but how could one
imprisoned man possibly take down one of
the world's most powerful armies
Fowler's connection with the West
allowed him to amass hundreds if not
thousands of guns something the Japanese
do not possess by aligning himself with
Shogun detractors such as Hai shindo and
master Chiba who have armies of their
own they can make quick work of the
Shogun who will be no match for this
Superior technology to make matters more
complicated we have princess aemi whose
father married her off to the shogun's
second eldest son something she's not
too pleased about she learns from one of
her handmaidens a former prostitute of
this impending attack and immediately
tells her father in an attempt to warn
everyone but to her surprise he already
knows in fact he wants the attack to
happen if the Shogun and his sons are
killed that means aemi will be next in
line to the throne the people will rally
around her and he will become the deao
ruler of Japan aemi has never had a
choice in her life as a woman she's
merely been a pawn of men her only
purpose to make babies and establish
alliances at the end of the season she
finally has the chance to make her own
choice run off with her former lover
Tagan or remain with her husband most of
the season has seen aimi searching for
what she wants in life and here she
makes her decision I want to be great
and she can only do that by remaining
where she is we've seen how aemi is a
master manipulator and even though she
is subservient to her husband if she can
control him it will give her tremendous
power I want to be in control of my life
then take control of him his the theme
of what it means to be great is
something espoused by almost every
character Ringo wants to be great at
something although he hasn't found out
just exactly what that is Mizu wants to
be a great swordsman and aemi desires
greatness it's aem's longtime Mentor
instructor and friend SEI voiced by
George teai that ends up saving a chemi
from her imprisonment they even end up
locking her father in a Cell as Fowler's
coup is set in motion the last we see of
her father Flames surround his cell
during the Great fire of 1657 of which
the last episode is titled this is an
actual fire that happened in Edo at the
time and estimates are that 100,000
people died in the show this fire is
depicted as starting when Mizu tries to
block Fowler's Escape it spread like
wildfire considering most of the
buildings at that time were made of
paper and wood no one knows how this
fire actually started but Japanese
Legend states that it was started
accidentally by a priest who was
cremating an allegedly cursed kimono
Fowler will later State biggest city in
the world is burning to the ground as a
blood sacrifice to your revenge the show
encompasses themes of hate and revenge
taking the stance that violence only
begets more violence mizu's quest for
Revenge has now resulted in the deaths
of over a 100,000 people had she never
embarked on this Quest she would have
never started the fire that killed so
many and that's not even counting the
dozens of others she kills on her
journey back to akim's Father the last
time we see him he's surrounded by
Flames but we learn that he survived a
chemi says that he needs time for quiet
recovery under her care so it's possible
he's severely burned and aemi has other
plans for him possibly to make him
suffer for what he did to her with
Fowler's men easily taking over the
castle they locate the Shogun and his
last remaining guards for over 20 years
Fowler had been secretly brokering deals
between the Shogun and the West making
the Shogun extremely rich while Fowler
was was treated like a second class
citizen his plan is to install a new
Shogun who will open Japan up to the
West Fowler kills the Shogun but before
he can finish off his kids is attacked
by Mizu allowing the next in line to the
throne to escape tan here is able to
kill Hai shindo the man who tortured him
at Fowler's Castle tan has had an
interesting season whereas Mizu
seemingly has no honor honor is
meaningless Tagan has too much of it in
episode one he's defeated by Mizu and
humiliated by having his Shong cut off
he spends most of the Season wanting to
reclaim his honor by challenging miso to
a duel but I got to say there are a few
moments where Mizu and Tagan Bond where
you kind of see a romantic connection
Brewing between these two and now that
the season ends with Tan's separated
from aemi I wouldn't be surprised if he
follows Mizu on her quest to London but
The Season's biggest reveals happened
during the epic showdown between Mizu
and Fowler Mizu has spent the majority
of her life training for this moment she
could could kill Fowler but decides not
to that's because she'll need Fowler to
hunt down the two remaining men she's
vowed to kill the two men are not in
Japan but London England in their brief
conversation we get a bit more
information about these men and mizu's
past first Fowler himself isn't sure if
he's mizu's father stating that he
thought he accounted for all his
bastards we also get the names of the
two other men Mizu are after and both of
them have physical qualities that could
make them mizu's Father there's
skeffington a tall man and rley a man
with pretty eyes the final shot of the
season is Mizu on a boat with an
imprisoned Fowler now we aren't sure if
season 2 will start immediately in
London or if it will follow miso's
journey to get there a trip from Japan
to England in the 1600s would entail
countless stops along the way I should
also mention the question of mizu's
mother bowler tells us that she was
murdered when Mizu was a baby but how
can that be if we saw her when Mizu was
an adult in episode 5 Mizu finds that
her mother is still alive but it's
actually not her mother at all it was
the maid who was paid to take care of
her until she chucked Mizu aside when
the money ran out this woman was an
opium addict and prostitute so when Mizu
arrives as an adult happy to see her
quote unquote mother again she sees this
as an opportunity and continues the ruse
of being her mother eventually marrying
Mizu off to a lord where she can live a
much more comfortable life it can
therefore be implied that it was this
woman who turned Mizu in for her Bounty
and episode 5 and not her husband so we
can see that mizu's life has been one of
constant betrayal no wonder her heart is
so full of hate she cares for nothing
but Revenge even if it means hurting
those around her if she's going to grow
as a character she'll need to heed
Master EG's words that the soul has two
chairs one for good and one for evil and
if you're not whole the demon will take
both it will be interesting to see how
mizu's journey to England will shape her
as a person will she let hatred consume
her or will she find a greater purpose
to her life than revenge but now I turn
it over to you what did you think of
Bluey Samurai I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much